congratulations on your victory today it
was really hard for the game what can
you say about it how did it go for you
it's a very hard game for me
i don't know what happens in the first
half of the game
before time control i think i misplayed
a more or less equal position but i
don't know where i went wrong position
so strange
i have a
better pawn structure and my
look is very good but my only weakness
is my king
and he
well i don't miss knight f5 when i if i
take on b2 he can
play knight d6 for example
so after that it's clear that i had to
defend
their hearts
but then somehow things went they were a
little bit better
yeah i was very lucky i found luke c8 i
see luke's eight when he played bishop
c5
and without this move i might lost
immediately after luke's eight maybe he
over pressed with queen b3 and e6
because after e6 my king became very
safe and
his pawn he postponed go nowhere since i
have very strong defender b5 bishop
maybe instead of
bishop c5
he had to play queen history
also he should be better
after e6 e7
i think i didn't have any problem
what was the turning point when you just
when you realized that your position is
is better yeah it was when he played
bishop israel he told me his cringy suit
i can see her
his face
got very nervous
actually after that i
i think i can pray for a win
so um and what was the last critical
moment in that game what do you think i
mean after that it was better for you
but when do you think it was completely
winning after the 16th move
after take on e8 with luke he he made
the sacrifice bishop with bishop g5
although he might not have the perpetual
check but he might exchange the queens
at some point and the resulting end game
might be
due in time not sure actually
but later on you managed to outplay him
and now actually you have three
victories in a row like how how happened
how do you feel
was it difficult for you yeah
today i can't believe it yeah
since at first i'm going to play for a
win but after the for this move it's
clear that i have to defend
a very sad position so there is the
results is totally surprising
yeah thank you very much and all the
best of luck in the next round thank you